carrie underwood and john legend carrie
underwood is the reigning queen of the
cmt awards
fans thank you so much
fans you guys you're the reason that we
are all
here doing what we do doing what we love
making music videos
it was a big night for the country
superstar at wednesday's ceremony
where carrie was nominated twice for
video of the year
and collaborative video of the year for
her song
hallelujah which she recorded with john
legend for her first ever
christmas album my gift in november of
[Music]
2020
carrie extended her title as the most
awarded performer
in cmt awards history and while carrie
accepted her
23rd cmt award she congratulated john
on his first john legend thank you for
sending me this incredible song
and agreeing to sing with me on it and
making this incredible
um video which i'm so proud of and
congratulations on what i think is your
first cmt award
carrie has won the award for video of
the year three years in a row
and this win marks her ninth time
winning it
overall i was voted into
this whole life you know being being on
american idol and
for people to still put that much time
and effort into voting and i think
that's so cool
carrie accepted her award in a vibrant
yellow suit
and dazzled in a sequin number for her
performance with need to breathe
rocking a sparkling black and white
nicholas jabron suit
which featured a mesh metal statement
belt
which she accessorized with big wavy
curls
and black boots carrie not only brought
her
fashion a game but her powerhouse vocals
as well
as she took to the stage for their
performance of
i wanna remember
[Music]
spoke with carrie just days before the
big night where she joked about her
winning streak
and how proud she was to be nominated
your talent is just
off the charts and you you never
disappoint this year you're going into
the award show with two more nominations
with that video with john legend for
hallelujah so
what would it mean taking home you know
continuing the winning streak if you
will i mean i'm always about padding the
numbers now
i i it's such a beautiful song and it's
it was such a beautiful video
and i'm just really proud that it was
nominated and
we'll see what happens what happened she
won
and what's next she's headed to sin city
for her reflection 12 show residency
in december which will take place at
resorts world las vegas
carrie told et what fans can expect from
the show
and that she's bringing her family along
for the ride
how is country carrie gonna go a little
sin city vegas style how are you gonna
shake your wardrobe up i mean i feel
like it's already
spot on you always knock it out of the
park with a wardrobe but how are you
going to spice it up for sin city
i mean i feel like vegas is just all
about
you know grandness and just things being
over the top and carrie you're already
grand whenever it comes to like your
wardrobe for performances you know
so well and i i feel like it's you know
it's all about it's going to be all
about the rhinestones all about the
fringe all about
i do change wardrobe you know throughout
shows and whatnot anyway so i feel like
this is just going to be a great
opportunity
to to be able to do that but you know we
just want to have fun we want the
audience to have fun